[Music]
welcome back to Hannity conservative
social media sensation Terrence Williams
our friend is back to give us the final
word tonight parents take away hey Sean
Hannity you ain't gonna believe what
Kruchten wrote a book Hillary Clinton
and guess what is called what happened
girl bah
we know what happened all right you got
molly-whopped in the election and Donald
Trump became your president that's what
happened but what we don't know is we
don't know what happened to them 33,000
emails they're true the leading to the
smashed up computers then smashed up
BlackBerry's we don't know what happened
on it we don't even know what happened
when you supposed to do your job and say
Benghazi we don't know what happened hey
you don't even know what happened with
that money you were supposed to give
them what happened to it Hillary
let us know what happened so Hillary
since you can't tell us what really
happened then you need to go home and
you need to go to bed and that's my
final word
all right thanks Terrence you also sent
me that t-shirt you need to go to bed
it's by the way I'll be doing it about
an hour from now well not really maybe
five